all right
welcome everybody uh my name is scott
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about
http security headers that you need to
have on your web apps
so if you'd like to follow along or view
the slides
after this i've already posted the
slides in slack
as well as they're up on my blog which
is my first and last name
scottsauber.com and i've also tweeted
them out so if you want to follow me on
twitter that's just again my first last
name
scott sauber on twitter
so before we get started i just want to
level set real quick
on the target audience i have with this
talk and hopefully this is most of you
but this is anybody with any sort of web
property so whether it's
a you know more traditional basic
website
or a more complex web app hopefully
you'll get a lot out of this talk
so hopefully that is you um if you are a
mobile developer or desktop developer
hopefully you'll still get something out
of this talk but primarily i'm targeting
web devs with this talk
so we're going to talk about what are
http security headers why should you
care about them
what are all these different security
headers what do they do
and i'll kind of do a before and after
showing you how your site performs
without them
versus with them as well as the impact
of adding this to an existing app that
you may have
because i'm guessing most of you are not
building purely green field apps
you'll you have some existing web
property
that you have to manage and so adding
some of these security headers which
we'll see a little bit later
uh can be a little dangerous and can
break your entire app
so i'll talk about how you can add some
of these things safely
as well as uh at the end of talking
about each one of these
i'll take some questions so if you want
to just drop them into the chat
i'll be happy to answer those kind of at
the end of talking about each one i'll
take a second to pause for some
questions and then we'll also do
questions
at the end as well so what i hope to get
i hope for you to get out of this is to
expose you to
the various security headers that are
out there and why you should care about
them
and hopefully you can write some of
those down before you head back to work
i'm not expecting that you're going to
memorize all of these
i often have to reference the docs
myself
so i'm not really expecting you to
memorize every single security header
out there just kind of expose you to
that security headers are a thing and
some ones that you may be
interested in so who am i
i'm a software consultant based in des
moines iowa
i am a co organizer of the iowa.net user
group
i'm also a friend of redgate and i blog
as i mentioned before
and i'm not a security expert per se
however
i have a background in financial
services
and health insurance and as part of that
you are subject to a lot of different
audits
and so one audit that is super common is
you get scanned you're like ex your
external facing websites and internal
facing websites get scanned by some
third party and as part of that they
often
check to see if you have any security
headers
and so this was something i dealt with
for many years and i first learned about
it from troy hunt who is speaking at
this
uh conference as well but after dealing
with with it
through a bunch of audits i thought this
was just kind of common knowledge and a
lot of people knew what security headers
are
because as part of this audit they check
to see hey do you have these certain
security headers and they ding you
if you do not but after talking to a lot
of developers at various conferences
and user groups and things like that i
found that like
eight or nine out of 10 developers
didn't know what security headers were
or had very limited knowledge about it
so that was kind of the genesis of this
talk
and so if you're not really familiar
with security headers don't worry i
would say you're
in the majority but that was kind of the
genesis of why i created this talk
so before we get into what are http
security headers let's just level set
real quick
and talk about what are http headers
so hp headers let the client and server
talk back and forth and pass some
additional data
between the client can send a request
header back to the server and the server
can
send a response header back to the
client just to exchange data back and
forth
so some example of request headers
things like cookies or what language
you're using
and that's where the browser is sending
that data to the server
and some response header examples are
things like what the data is what the
content type is
as well as any security related headers
and that's what we're going to be
focused on today so this is something
that the
a server is sending down to the browser
so what are http security headers then
so security security headers are again
response headers that the server tells
the browser to enforce some extra
security rules when
dealing with your website's content so
we'll take a look
here in a little bit about what that
means exactly but basically it just
informs the browser hey
put these things in a sandbox or
restrict access to these parts
these features of the browser and again
we'll take a look at that here in a
minute
they're just key value pairs just like a
normal http header
and in general the more security headers
you send
the more secure your website is now
there are definitely
some security headers that lock down
your security more than others but in
general that's a good rule of thumb is
the more you send the more
secure your website is most security
headers
allow you to tweak the settings of them
so you can
tweak the behavior of what those
security headers do
to the behavior that you desire for your
website
so i'm sure many of you have cracked
open the chrome dev tools but if you
haven't how you can look at the security
headers
is you crack open the dev tools and go
the network tab
which is number one there and then click
on a request
so number two there and then you can
inspect the headers
and see what headers a
server is sending down so you can see
there there's a few dealing with
security and we'll talk about pretty
much
all of the ones that deal with security
all right let's jump right into our
first security header which is
http strict transport security or hsts
so what is hsts well it allows websites
to tell web browsers to
only ever request this site over https
don't ever request it over http
why should you care about that exactly
well it prevents
some and i'm emphasizing some classes of
men
in the middle attacks so what happens to
your site without hsts
let's say you're on on a browser and the
user types in you know something.com but
they don't put the https at the
beginning right
by default that's going to go over http
so that's going to go all the way to the
server
and then the server is going to be like
well actually i only respond to requests
over https
so then the server is going to go ahead
and tell the browser to make this
request over https
the browser is then going to say okay
i'll request that over https
and then the server will finally serve
up the content right
but what's the problem here i'll give
you a second to think about that
what could be the problem
the hint is it's in number one there
so the problem is a lot uh or all this
communication happens
over the internet so what can happen is
if you are
on a wi-fi access point that has been
compromised by
a man in the middle who's monitoring all
the traffic
what can happen is you type in
something.com and maybe that's like a
popular financial institution for
instance and the man in the middle is
kind of
waiting for somebody to type that in so
they can serve up their malicious
content that looks very similar to what
that financial
institution is so then you plug in your
credentials and then boom they have your
username and password
so then the man in the middle can serve
up that malicious content like i said
and then the user has been compromised
or can be compromised depending on what
actions they take
on that malicious content so what
happens in
with hsts instead is when the user
types in something.com that first
request will go over http however it
will never actually leave the browser
so the browser does a 307 internal
redirect
to hpsomething.com and at that point
uh your browser negotiates with the
server and bypasses the man in the
middle attack
assuming he hasn't compromised like your
certificates and things like that
and at that point even if you're on a
compromise network
you can bypass the man in the middle
attack and
still serve everything over hps so it'll
secure your users
and not have them potentially get served
malicious content from that man in the
middle
so what does that look like exactly so
this is an example
of hsts so you can see
on the left there it says strict dash
transport security
is the key and then there's a few
different options
so for instance max age is the number of
the seconds the browser should enforce
hsts
so by default or not by default but a
common
thing you will see is 31 536
000 which is one year and so what this
means is it tells the browser to hey
only request h https for this site
for this many seconds so um
if you put in like obviously six months
it's only gonna
and the user visit doesn't visit your
site for six months in one day
uh they their next request if it's over
http will not do an internal redirect
it'll just go
all the way to the server and back
include subdomains means apply this to
all subdomains
and then there's this preload option
which tells the browser to put your site
on a preload list and we'll talk about
that here in a second
max age is required but the other two
are not
because it wouldn't really make sense if
you didn't put a max age
or a max age of zero for instance
because then the browser
will only add your site to that list for
zero seconds which means it'll never
actually be on there and never actually
apply
so i mentioned the preload list so what
is that exactly
so this is a list maintained by google
but it's used by all the major browsers
if you are not on this list then the
first http request
will do a 301 which will open up the
chance for that man in the middle so
it'll do that first
graphic that i showed where it'll go all
the way to the server and back
however if you are on this list then the
hp request that you
perform will do a 307 internal redirect
not a 301
so even if you've never visited the site
before because again
the server is the one instructing the
browser how to
handle uh these headers
if even if you've never visited the site
before so the server's never actually
told you what header secure is about
it will do the internal uh 307 redirect
for you
if you are on the preload list so again
this guarantees no chance of a basic
man in the middle attack you can submit
your domain to hsp
hstspreload.org and that preload option
that i mentioned on the last slide is
kind of your way of confirming your
submission
because obviously you could go to the
site and plug in anybody's url
but the preload option tells you hey yes
i do in fact want to be on this preload
list
so it's kind of like when you sign up
for a website and you sign up with an
email
and they send you an email confirmation
that you have to click a link it's kind
of like that where you
you're just confirming your submission
by adding that preload option
all right let's do a demo of hsts
so i've got the site here and so i'll
just reconnect here
and so i did my initial request over
http
and so if i scroll up here you can see
the first request was over http
and it did a 301 redirect
so it went all the way to the server and
then came back
and so you can see then it said hey you
need to request this over https and so i
did
that request and
so i did the https request on the second
request but you can see this one went
all the way to the server because it did
a 301
on this one on the other hand oops i
don't want to leave the meeting
wrong hotkey that would have been a bad
one so if i make this request over hp
https
this site is enforcing hsts
and so you can see this first one is
over http but it did a 307
internal redirect this time and so hsts
is also like a slight performance
improvement too because you can see
there are no
bytes that were actually sent over the
wire and the time was one millisecond
whereas over here
you can see there's actually
i'm not sure why that says one
millisecond must have been
cash or something but um normally you
wouldn't see you would see like some
uh size coming back and so like htcs
again reduces the size
the amount of requests that are actually
going to your server because that one
actually went
all the way to the server and back i'm
surprised that it doesn't say a size in
time but
that's okay all right
so some hsts gotchas
you probably don't want to do this while
you're running on localhost unless every
single website that you have running
locally is on https
but even if it is hps and http often
listen on different ports so you might
have localhost 5000 for http
and 5001 for https so if you try and
visit localhost 5000 it'll redirect you
to https localhost 5000 which
uh will not bind because your site's not
list your server's not listening
for https on that port
so what's the impact of putting this on
an existing app
you have to ask yourself is everything
really hps
because if it's not this will not work
so are all of your images
and all of your requests you're making
over hps
you have to also a question about
subdomains like all do you need to add
the include subdomains
attribute or not and i don't know why
you would do this but if for some reason
you are planning on going from https to
http in the future
then you probably want to consider
limiting your max age down on hsts
because
the users that visit your site will
request your site only over https for
the duration
of that max age again i don't know why
you would ever do this but if for some
reason you're planning on doing that
that is something to consider
so quick word on https
i hear some people say like oh i don't
need to do it because my site's internal
well i think it's a good idea even if
your site is
internal if it's external there's no
doubt you should be doing hps by now
the reason is your network topology may
change
obviously more and more things are
moving to the cloud nowadays
and with covid many of us are working
from home
so even if your users could maybe maybe
you're hosting on-prem
uh with your internal site and your
users could like see the network closet
from their desk uh
obviously with kovid they're probably
working from home now and over a vpn or
something like that
so it's a good idea to just secure your
traffic with https
in general and add it to your site even
if it's internal
as well as there's the perception factor
thanks to chrome because
chrome will now alert if your site is
not secure
so you don't want to have to explain to
users like oh well it's fine and
have their eyes gloss over when you try
and explain like how networking works or
something like that
there's just a perception factor uh as
well to consider especially as users get
more security conscious with all the
breaches
that seem to be happening nowadays
so with that i'll pause for
probably 10 seconds or so for any
questions on hsts i don't see any
coming through yet but again i'll
pause kind of after demoing these things
and so if you have any questions just
keep popping them in
and i'll answer it on the next go-round
don't see any coming in so i'm going to
go ahead and move on to the next one
all right the next one we're going to
talk about is x-frame options or xfo
so what is it well it tells a browser
whether or not your page should be
rendered in a frame or an iframe
why do you care about that exactly well
it prevents
click check click jacking attacks so
what
are click well we'll talk about in a
little bit what a click jacking attack
is
but what extreme options gives you is it
prevents click jacking attacks
so what does x frame options look like
basically it's really simple you just
tell it how you want to handle framing
so deny prevents any site from framing
your page which is the most secure
same origin allows framing only from the
same domain
and allow from allows you to allow list
add some sites to the allow list so you
can say that that site in this case
site1.com
can frame your page so let's do
a quick demo of x-frame options
so i've got the site here and so this is
a new site i just created
it's very fancy you say click here to
like on facebook you click the button
and it says thanks for the facebook like
right very very fancy
so let's go to a another site
that says click here to download the
coupon code right
i like coupon codes everybody likes to
save money so i'm going to go ahead and
click that button
but when i do i get this weird pop-up
that says thanks for the facebook like
which seems a little strange right i was
trying to download a coupon code
so what's happening is this
is my original site where i clicked and
said thanks for the facebook like
is being framed over the top of this
button here
and so if i and you can see i'm setting
the opacity here to zero so if i get rid
of that you can see it's framed in such
a way that i'm think i'm clicking on
this button but really i'm clicking on
this button
and so this can also happen to your
internal sites as well
so say your users are visiting some
malicious
external site and somebody knows
about that that particular user has
access to a certain site
if they can frame your site in such a
way that they click on
a malicious button that's really
clicking on a real button
you can actually have them perform
actions on an internal site
and you can try this out if you want you
can just go to
any site like external sites like some
codepen or something like that
that's got an iframe and try and frame a
local host and it will totally work
unless you turn on xframe
so right here i'm going to say x frame
options deny
which will then not allow my site to be
framed in any way by any site even my
own
and i'm doing using asp.net core here um
and i'm doing this kind of manually
normally i would use some sort of
library like n-web sec
or if you're on node there's a library
called helmet which is also really good
but i'm just gonna do this in the manual
way so you can kind of see the key value
pairs
a little bit easier those kind of give
you more convenience methods
so if i come back over here to this uh
site after i've
rebuilt my page and i'm clicking i don't
think you can really hear me click but
i'm clicking
and nothing's happening and you can see
over here in the console that it says
it refused to display this in a frame
because extreme options was set to deny
and if you actually look at the iframe
here it's basically just a bunch of
error messages
and stuff like that so my content wasn't
actually framed whatsoever
so that is a demo of click checking
attacks
and how extreme options can prevent them
so what's the impact of putting this on
an existing app that does not have it
yet
basically you have to ask yourself do
you know which sites should be framing
or iframing your app
i imagine most sites could do a deny or
at the very least the same origin
or they could just allow a specific site
i know some
what some people do when they're
transitioning to a brand new site
is they'll take the old site and add
some iframes in there and start
framing in the new site and so i know
that's a tactic
tactic that some people use or they go
the other way and have the
new site frame in the old site so you
just kind of have to know what your
application is doing and whether or not
you have those scenarios
any questions on x frame options
don't see any yet
wait another five seconds or so see if
any roll in
but again i'll kind of do these pauses
so just keep dropping them in
and i will answer it when i get to the
next go around
all right the next thing we're going to
talk about is how to prevent
cross-site scripting but before we talk
about how to prevent it let's just level
set again real quick on what cross-site
scripting
is so cross-site scripting is a
vulnerability in a trusted website
so a completely legitimate website where
malicious scripts can be
injected so cross-site scripting can
be used to harvest things like cookies
tokens
the content on the page that kind of
thing and then ship it off to
malicious attackers servers since
the script that loaded appears to be
legitimate
so this usually comes in the form of
a user types in some data and then they
hit save
and then that data is not validated or
encoded
in any way and it gets redisplayed to
that user
so some examples of this uh again you
just take some input from the user and
save it into the database
so you inject that militia or somebody
puts that malicious script and it gets
saved to the database
and then that script runs on other pages
that other people can see or maybe that
link gets shared so think
things like twitter or facebook right if
you send out a tweet or post a status
update on facebook
and let's say one of those sites had a
cross-site scripting vulnerability well
now that tweet
and that post goes to everybody who's
following that person
or is friends with that person uh so
then that
malicious script starts running on all
these different people's browsers which
would obviously be really bad
another common example i see that uh can
get missed
is like a contact us or feedback form
page where
um maybe you're just taking that input
and firing off an email
from one of those things uh can you put
a script or maybe a
css file in there and does it get loaded
by your email clients
so that's another example of where
cross-site scripting can burn you as
well
so let's just do an example here real
quick of cross-site scripting
so i've got this input where when i type
test
i just redisplay what the user input
right
so if instead i put in a script where i
just say script alert
hi hit submit you can see here it's
actually running the script and
showing hi so you can imagine this would
be like harvesting
some like tokens you have a local
storage or something like that
and shipping them off to another server
so what's worse on this is i'm also
putting the message in the url
so this is another common thing is
sometimes people put messages here in
the url
and then just redisplay them back and
don't do any sort of
uh validation or encoding which would
also
uh not be good depending on if you
aren't handling that
in the correct way so that
is an example and also people could like
share this link to
so if you even if you're doing this and
not saving it to the database somebody
could
share this link to somebody else and get
them to click it
and then boom that script runs on uh
their browser as soon as they click it
and then potentially bad things could
happen right
all right so that was an example of what
cross-site scripting is so final note
most modern frameworks out there help
you out
for those of you who use asp.net core i
have to specifically override
the razer syntax and call html.raw since
it encodes by default
and react if you're using react on the
front end
it just escapes non-props characters by
default
not props characters just any non-props
characters by default so that also helps
you out
a little bit
any questions about cross-site scripting
before we talk about how we're going to
prevent
cross-site scripting there's a few
different ways we're going to talk about
that
still not seeing anything so i'm going
to keep going on
all right so cross-site scripting can be
prevented in a few different ways
um so it can be printed using a content
security policy
which can help you prevent other attacks
not just cross-site scripting we'll take
a look at that here in a second
there is an old security header called
x-xss-protection
but that is really no longer honored by
any major browser out there
but if you're familiar with that one or
if you have that on your site
that doesn't get respected by just about
any major browser any longer and you can
click that link for more details if
you're interested
in that basically what that used to do
is it used to analyze your page
and say like hey do i think cross-site
scripting is happening here and if it
did it took an action to either block
or just like cleanse your page from it
but they no longer have that protection
because it just caused some other issues
and there are actually some security
vulnerabilities in it and things like
that
so let's talk about content security
policy so what content security policy
is about
is how your browser loads the static
assets both how
they load them like are they uh inline
scripts or inline styles
and where they load them from so is it
loading from your own
site is it loading from a cdn that kind
of thing
why should you care about that well i
can reduce or even eliminate
a cross-site scripting attack from being
able to happen
and just limits your attack service on
other kinds of attacks which we'll talk
a little bit more about that later
so content security policy what it looks
like is you just say
i'm configuring scripts so i say script
sort and for like styles i do style dash
source and we'll talk about some other
ones here in a little bit
so this is the content that i'm
configuring
the domain that the page is being served
on so in this case i'm saying
i'm allowing myself to load scripts or
to load scripts from myself i should say
and the rest are the other domains that
you allow
scripts to be loaded from so in this
case maybe i've got google analytics on
my site so i need to
i'll allow google dash analytics.com and
google.com
some other values you can put here you
can add an unsafe
inline which means allow script tags
uh like inline on your page rather than
loading them from an external file
or it'll also allows inline event
handlers that are wired up like on the
html
itself so like an on click event for
instance so if you say like button on
click equals then the name of your
javascript function
that would also be an example of a
inline
wire up of javascript so you would have
to add the unsafe dash
inline to your security policy in order
to allow that
and then none means block any use of
this content type
so if i say script source none
that means i will not load any
javascript whatsoever
which kind of by definition then i'm not
really susceptible to cross-site
scripting vulnerabilities if my site
doesn't even allow javascript to be
loaded
you can also add this report-uri option
which allows you to receive
a json payload with any violation
information
so for instance if somebody tries to
execute
a cross-site scripting attack on your
site and you block it
this you'll get a json payload to that
uri that you specify
and it will tell you like what page it
was on what what tried to happen
and all that kind of information so then
you can like look into it in case
somebody's trying to be malicious on
your site and that kind of thing
we'll talk a little bit later about
where else the report uri could be
useful as well
so like any allow list in general the
more you allow
the greater your risk so if you allow
any
javascript to be loaded from like any s3
bucket and amazon or something like that
or any
um cdn just like put in a bunch of cdns
there
obviously you're opening yourself up to
somebody uh uploading a malicious script
to one of those cdns
and being able to execute a cross-site
scripting vulnerability on your site
not allowing inline scripts is one of
the biggest wins
if you can manage it but i know a lot of
existing sites use inline scripts and
some spa frameworks
such as react do not support disabling
inline scripts
but if you can manage it i would highly
recommend turning off
inline scripts just like script
source there's a ton of other ones uh
that
behave similarly so style dash source
media dash source
frame dash source font dash source and a
bunch of other ones you can go look them
up
you can probably guess what all of those
configure
all of these take in domains to allow
and unsafe inline also works with styles
so if you have like an inline style tag
and you're not loading that css from an
external
css file unsafe inline also works with
those
and none also works with all of them as
well so
if you want no one to frame your content
you can also
use none and security policy to prevent
people from framing your content
so let's do a quick content security
policy demo
so unfortunately i couldn't figure out
how to get the audio to work very well
on this so you're just going to have to
bear with me but
um before we get into content security
policy
do people remember the harlem shake
which is popular like in 2013-ish time
frame
so what the harlem shake is is basically
somebody dances and is dancing around
one prey and
by the way i swear i'm gonna test back
to school but somebody's sitting there
dancing
someone kind of builds up and then
eventually it hits like
a certain point and then everybody kind
of goes crazy right
so you can actually make your site do
the harlem shake
so if i come over here and go to content
security policy page
there's a script here and this is in my
slides if you want to grab this
i can make my site
this can happen is because i actually
don't have
a good content security policy enforced
on my site
so we will talk about how to prevent
your site from being harlem shopkin
as well here in a second so
okay and so if
so in this case i'm going to say i want
to add a content uh security policy
i'm going to allow uh scripts from
myself
i'm going to allow styles for myself i'm
going to allow images for myself
as well as from google.com and i'm not
gonna allow
any sort of media right so
pretty straightforward on what all that
is doing
so on this page and i forgot to call it
out before i made this change
but i had an inline script here show
that
where did i put the inline script so
right here i'm just saying alert
this is from an inline script so you may
have seen
i got a pop-up earlier before i made
this change
and so it's saying hey uh i'm not going
to allow you to execute that inline
script
because you only allow scripts from
yourself
you need to either add the unsafe inline
keyword or add some sort
of hash that represents the contents of
the script or add a nonce
to allow this script to be executed but
in this case
i totally broke my app so if i was
dependent on this inline script
then i totally just broke my app because
i unsafely
um i didn't add the unsafe inline and my
app depended on it
but this site this picture here is
actually loaded from
google.com and because i allowed that in
my content security policy
specifically so right here it still
allowed me to load
that external resource from google.com
what happens when i do
this so the only real change here i made
was i'm saying style dash source none
so what do you think that's going to do
before i go back to the site i'll give
you
like probably 5 10 seconds to think
about that
so style dash source none well it means
your site is going to not do what i
expected hold on let me refresh
there we go that's better so it's going
to make your site look a lot like
craigslist right
where there's just like no styling
whatsoever it's just com
like all the css was completely not
allowed to be loaded so you can see here
it tried to load the site.css file but
it violated
the content security policy because i
said don't allow any styles whatsoever
so this is kind of what i'm saying is
what i'm trying to get across here
is if you don't configure this correct
stuff correctly
you will break your entire site from
functioning and make people
very unhappy so this is kind of one of
those things that you kind of have to
like ideally you would add this when
you're right away when you're building a
new site
um so adding it to an existing site can
be kind of tricky but i'll talk about an
example of how you can do this
safely and incrementally add this to
your site
all right i'm just going to go ahead and
disable that because i actually do want
css to be loaded for
a future demo all right
so again the impact of putting this on
an existing app
is huge because again this is an allow
list so you have to know
everything about what your app is doing
and where like how it's loading the
assets whether in line or not
and where it's loading them from such as
what cdns and all that kind of stuff
as mentioned configuring wrong will
break your app
but there is a compromise here so you
can set content security policy to
only report and not actually enforce
the policy itself so rather than doing
content dash security dash policy
you do content dash security dash policy
dash report dash only
and at that point it's just going to
collect that data and report back to
that report uri
that we talked about earlier and so you
can kind of collect
data over a period of time and so like
that period of time is going to depend
on your app
right so some maps may be safe like
flipping it on for real after a month
in some apps maybe you only have a
feature that gets used once a year so
you just have to kind of
kind of depends on what your application
is but after some certain period of time
when you get no more violations
so you're confident that your app isn't
breaking
then you can actually flip on the
content security policy for real
and start enforcing it as well as this
kind of lets you
identify like if you got a huge app that
you're kind of like
wrestling to understand and um you want
to like
get rid of all the inline scripts and
inline styles you can start converting
those incrementally because it'll report
back to you
which uh app which resources are getting
or would have gotten blocked but it
won't actually block them it'll allow
your app to continue functioning
so as i kind of touched on briefly
content security policy can override
your need for other
headers so for instance frame dash
ancestors
none means no one can embed the page in
a frame or iframe
which eliminates the need for x-frame
options
so that's equivalent to x-frame options
deny
however um most security if you're if
you get auto
audited by a third party a lot of these
people um just kind of run their scanner
tool
and maybe do some manual um
breaking it trying to break into your
apps and a lot of them like to see
those headers set as well even if though
they're
they're redundant um some of it is to do
with some browsers don't support
some of these things um but like content
security policy
has been around for a long time so any
any modern browser over the last few
years should support uh what content
security policy has
but honestly it doesn't really hurt
anything to duplicate some of these
security headers
and have both like frame ancestors none
and x frame options deny
so it'll make the security people happy
so you can just go ahead and add both
even though
one takes precedence over the other
any question and content security policy
i haven't seen any role in so far so
i'll just keep talking for another few
seconds in case somebody's got something
all right now keep going now then
so this next one um is really
only applicable if you're supporting ie
and compatibility view so i'm going to
kind of buzz through this one real quick
so this is called x content type options
so what is that exactly well it tells a
browser to not sniff the response
to try and determine how it should
render that response
so normally how a browser works is uh
looks at the content type header and
says okay this is html i'll render this
as html
what browsers used to do is they used to
like sniff the response and say oh i
think this is javascript i'll just go
ahead and execute it as javascript
which could be bad depending on what
your app's doing so for instance if
you're taking like
a text file from a user and redisplaying
it to them
uh x content without x content type
options and again
this only applies if you're working with
like ie and compatibility view
i.e and compatibility view might read
that text file and say like oh i think
this is javascript i'm going to go ahead
and try and execute it which is
something they never should have done
but unfortunately they did
in older browsers so what you can do is
you can say hey
don't sniff the response with by saying
x dash content dash type dash
options and say no sniff instead that
just looks at the content type header
and renders it as that so it's kind of
like trusting your server to know what
kind of content type it
is what's the impact of putting this on
an existing
app it's probably pretty minimal again
most modern browsers will not sniff by
default but
if you are some poor poor person who has
to support and happen to ie and
compatibility view
first off i'm so sorry but second off
you may have to
see if your app is depending on this
sniffing behavior
um it probably isn't so like 99.9
percent
of apps probably aren't relying on this
behavior but
if your app only works compatibility
view it may be doing some other really
goofy things it shouldn't be doing so
you just kind of have to know again what
your app is doing for most of us
out there who don't have to support that
you can just flip this on
and it's no big deal and it'll make the
security auditors happy
so as mentioned still shows up on audits
so even if you don't support
ie in any sort shape or form because i
is no longer supported by microsoft
um they still like to see it on security
audits so you can just add it it's
really no big deal
so any questions on that i'm gonna guess
not
all right i'm gonna go on to the next
security header
but before we talk about the next
security header i'm going to
give you a background on a regular http
header called
referrer so what happens when you're on
a site
and you don't have any sort of chrome
extension or anything else that's
preventing this
is say you're on site a and site a has a
link to site b
and when you click you're on site and
you click up the link to site b
it's going to send that data through the
referrer header telling site b
hey you actually came uh this person
came from site a
so that's what the browser will send to
the server by default
so this is actually really useful for
tracking a user's flow through an
application
but obviously there's some potential
privacy concerns
there as well and yes it is
misspelled so it is ref e
single r er but for the spelling
aficionados out there
it should be r e f e double r er
but they wrote it in the spec with a
single r and so the next time you
feel bad about a misspelling that you
accidentally send out to the entire
company
at least the entire internet wasn't
based on your misspelling
in a uh http specs so
it could be worse and yes that was
actually how it shows up in the browser
they don't rewrite it or anything like
that
so i've actually seen this on my blog so
i host on wordpress just because it's
cheap and it's simple
i don't do any of the js gatsby or any
of the
jam stack stuff and uh pre-render all
the content
i just host on wordpress but a feature
of wordpress is they tell me
hey where did people come from which is
really useful for me because i'm like oh
cool
uh somebody's linking to a blog post of
mine on github so i can go see
like where that is and kind of see if
people are asking questions
or something like that and i can answer
them which is really useful to me right
the problem is i also have this long
tail of
people's internal jiras or internal
confluences
or their outlook web access where i can
know what these urls
are which i'm gonna guess if they knew
that i knew some of this stuff
this probably wouldn't be ideal and they
probably wouldn't be thrilled about this
i mean it's kind of cool for me to know
that uh some of these companies are
linking to my blog but i'm guessing they
wouldn't be super thrilled
with me knowing that so this is kind of
the problem with the refer header where
if you link to something and you click
it
and your uh browser a browser extension
isn't preventing this
or your site isn't enforcing what we're
going to talk about next
then it's just going to send what the
source page was
straight on to the destination server
so that is where referrer policy comes
in
so it tells a browser what should be
sent in the referrer header
why should you care about that well it
helps protect the identity of the source
of a page's visit
so it has is actually spelled correctly
so it's r e f
e double r er dash policy that so they
didn't proliferate that mistake
and so you can say like no referrer
which means don't send the referrer
header at all which is the most secure
you can say only send the origin origin
so don't send the full url like
example.com wax index.html just send
example.com
you can say only send it to my same
origin so if i'm
site a and site b again i'll only send
it if i'm clicking a link to site a
so if i'm clicking a link to myself but
i will not send it when i'm going to
site b
and there's a ton of other options that
you can figure this to your heart's
content
and you can go look at the mdn official
docs for that or click that link
as well and it'll take you to all the
different options there
so what's the impact of putting this on
an existing app
um i think it's pretty minimal with
right config again you kind of have to
know what your app is doing and whether
or not you use the referrer header for
anything
i'm going to guess most sites uh
probably aren't doing very much with the
referrer header so you could probably
just turn it off in general or at the
very least
just say only allow it to send to myself
any refer policy questions
i gave this talk before some dude was
freaking out because
uh he didn't know the refer header
existed
and he apparently he told me uh the next
day
at the conference that i made him lose
sleep the previous night so
i don't know exactly what he was doing
and what sites he was visiting but
apparently this freaked him out pretty
good
all right so no questions i'm gonna go
on to the next one
so the next one we're going to talk
about is feature policy which is
currently experimental and i'll talk a
little bit later about
uh what it's kind of getting replaced by
but it's in this sort of weird state
right now
so what is it it tells a browser to
allow
or deny the use of certain javascript
features
and allows you to granular uh have some
granularity to say hey
only allow these certain javascript
features or allow only allow these
specific
domains to execute those javascript
features
so you can kind of think about third
party code you're in bed
so why should you care about this um
well if you have a cross-site scripting
vulnerability it restricts what your own
app can do
so if you lock certain javascript
features down
it prevents some of the features that
the cross-site scripting vulnerability
could execute
as well as it allows you to restrict
what third-party code can do
so i know a lot of times as developers
we get told from marketing to embed
something
on our pages we can actually
lock down what that code is doing so it
doesn't do any
things that it shouldn't be doing so you
can do things like block geolocation the
camera
microphone all those kind of javascript
apis
and there is limited browser support
right now and a rename is coming in the
future to permissions policy
again it's kind of in a weird state
we'll talk about that here in a second
but feature policy is at least partially
implemented
in pretty much every modern browser out
there or it's
fully implemented so you can start using
this today
so what future policy looks like is you
say what are what's the feature you're
locking down such as camera geolocation
microphone etc
and then this is your allow list of who
can use that feature so you can say star
for anybody
or self or none or type in a url
and so that's kind of how feature policy
works is you just give it what the
future is
and what you're locking down all right
future policy demo time
so i'm going to go over here and so this
is going to be the awkward part
of the talk because i have to stop my
video because i'm going to use the video
from the browser and so hopefully you
can see this
that looks like you can that i'm showing
up here in the browser
now instead of through webex because
apparently you can't have two camera
two things talking to your camera at
once and so i'm using the camera feature
of javascript
to uh display this right
so let's go over here and
say i want to add my feature policy and
say camera
none which means nobody can use the
camera api from javascript
right so if i come back over here you
notice i'm completely gone
i'm going to turn back on my webex video
and you can see here in the console it
says permission denied right
so again this is one of those things
that you kind of have to know what your
web app's doing
in order to turn on or off various
javascript features
but you can think of like if you
embedded third-party code or maybe
if somebody if you had a cross-site
scripting vulnerability on your app
that cross-site scripting vulnerability
couldn't use the camera api
in my case with the way i've configured
this web app
so again this is a pretty big i'd say
it's probably pretty much equivalent to
content security policy
although you're targeting specific
features so it's not as bad because like
if
you configure content security policy
wrong you could say like don't load
javascript at all or don't load css at
all which would be really bad
um but you have to know what your site
is doing so if you care about the camera
api
you can't really turn it off and so
again you just have to know exactly
what features your site's doing and what
they're leveraging
so i mentioned features policy they're
kind of renaming it
and rebranding it to this permissions
policy thing
it's pretty much the same idea as
feature policy so these two
policies are equivalent uh it's just
slightly different where you say like
camera equals
instead of just camera space and then
you pass it this like array
of uh things to allow as well as
none is now replaced by an empty
parenthesis to say
nobody can a lot we can't allow
geolocation
to be used on this website so again this
is the feature you're locking down
and those are the sites that are allowed
to use that feature in this case the
camera
so permissions policy is not really
supported anywhere yet
except behind a flag in chrome
so you can't really start using this yet
it's just a working draft spec but
they've already talked about how
permissions policy is eventually going
to replace feature policy so you can
use feature policy today and browsers
will enforce that as you saw on
an earlier slide but permissions policy
just isn't quite there yet
this is kind of one of those things that
they changed their mind and
renamed it to permissions policy to be a
little bit more explicit as well as
there's some syntactic things that they
wanted to do that now they'll be able to
do with permissions policy
but again this is just a working draft
spec and so this is still
kind of experimental and they may change
their mind
yet again we shall see
so any questions about feature policy or
permissions policy
i haven't seen any roll through yet
give it another few seconds all right
well just pop something into the chat
again i'll hit it at the end
so those are kind of al all the major
uh security features that you have to
worry about so you may ask yourself okay
how do i test my website today
well there's a site called
securityheaders.com which is run by
scott helm who is doing a talk here at
ndc
i believe tomorrow or maybe the day
after i don't remember
and he runs a site that allows your site
to be scanned
so what you do is you plug in your url
on
securityheaders.com so in this case i'm
plugging in facebook.com
and you'll definitely want to check that
box right there that says hide results
because if you don't then you could end
up here in the hall of fame or the hall
of shame
so you can see they're kind of keeping
track of how well people do
and unfortunately 70 million people out
of 127 million so
over half got an f and just about 10
so about 14 million sites
got a a or an a plus so
as you can see this is definitely kind
of as i mentioned earlier i think a lot
of people aren't really aware of
security headers
and so when only about 10
of the internet traffic that has kind of
been plugged into the site is getting an
a or an a plus you can definitely see
there's a lot of
room for improvement out there so when
you click the scan button
it's going to say hey you got an a
and these are the headers that you added
and these are the headers that you did
not add it gives you some nice
information such as hey you're missing
these headers here's what they are
so you can go add them to your site so
you can see
they're already calling out permissions
policy so they're kind of being really
proactive
even though some browsers aren't uh
haven't implemented that yet but as they
do
um obviously those permissions will
start those policies will start getting
enforced
and it's also giving you a warning so
saying like hey this policy contains
unsafe inline
you probably shouldn't be doing that go
ahead and try and
switch to not allow unsafe inline
scripts
and the other nice thing is it allows
you
uh to uh or it tells you what
upcoming headers are coming so it kind
of keeps you
aware of things that are coming down the
road and things that the browser vendors
are thinking about
as well as it tells you some information
about the security headers you have
added so
if you want to scan your site um because
you just kind of haven't been exposed to
this
you can see what's what headers have
been added to your site
and again it gives you a description of
what all of those are
so kind of a final note um
if you're using some sort of web app
firewall such as cloudflare and capsula
or one of those they these web app
firewalls often
have options to configure these for you
in my opinion
i'd rather let the app add these uh for
a few reasons
one to avoid vendor lock-in so you could
switch to a new web app firewall
pretty quickly as well as getting
localhost to run
as closely to prod as possible so
i would be very terrified if i had a
different content security policy
running locally than i did in production
because then it's just kind of like
you're just testing for the very first
time in production which would be
terrifying
and sometimes this is hard to do if
you're doing like more of a jam stack
where you're just kind of plopping
a spa on a cdn somewhere
but in aws's case you can use lambda
edge to run run a bit of code
before it serves up your assets from the
cdn
so you can add some security headers by
using lambda
edge and i have not seen an equivalent
in azure or gcp
but if somebody knows of one uh drop it
in the chat because i'd love to hear it
because i tried looking for it and i
couldn't exactly find it
so some takeaways hopefully i brought
some
uh security header awareness to you if
you weren't exposed to them previously
or
if there were one new ones that kind of
popped popped in that you weren't aware
of either
and hopefully you've got at least one
hdp header that you're like oh i should
totally do that and you can
write that down and look back to it when
you get into work
as well as the other takeaway i want you
to get out of this is
security headers are kind of an evolving
field right
so you kind of need to keep your pulse
on this and
watch what's coming down the pipe
because they're adding more and more
security headers to the spec
so maybe this is something you check
back in maybe once a year or so
to see what the latest status of some of
these security headers are so you stay
up to date with the latest security
headers
as well as securityheaders.com to check
out your websites
and just the fact that the web is a
scary place
i mean i know when i was
first starting out uh doing web stuff
and somebody showed me like cross-site
scripting vulnerabilities and stuff like
that
i was pretty terrified and so if you
kind of hadn't been exposed to some of
that stuff before hopefully
it just brings some awareness so that
security is kind of top of mind while
you're building your web apps
so i've got a bunch of links to some
resources
and you can go to securityheaders.com or
the mdn website
i've also got a link uh to this on my
github
and troy hunt has a really good
pluralsight on security headers as well
he's kind of one of the first people i
learned some of the stuff from
so i'd highly recommend that as well
so with that any questions
so roman had a few comments it looks
like so he said just an observation
regarding https sometimes you can be
fooled by missing hsts headers for a
subdomain however in case
when the second level domain is on a
preload list subdomains do
subdomains do not have to send it but
the browser is aware
and then regarding xf0 many times you
can see duplicate headers
with even different values in the
responses with an app and a web app
firewall
or in the rfc the browser should
concatenate the values which they likely
don't do and fall back to the safe
default option
cool i did not know that and another
note about xfo for unauthenticated apps
this can be bypassed with proxy options
such as x-frame bypass
csp is a safer option yes for sure i
would
highly recommend not relying on
x-frame options for that and use csp so
like one kind of trick
to know on some of these headers is it
as like an x dash
prefix that usually means it's an older
header
and if it doesn't have an x dash prefix
that means it's probably a newer header
and so they're probably enforcing things
a little bit stricter on a lot of those
so just fyi as you're looking through
these as well but thanks roman those are
all good
info to share
you